also leute das ist so echt das heftigste
was ich bisher bei change act mitgemacht
habe ich weiß das sag ich oft aber
diesmal wirklich mit solchen handschuhen
zu spielen ist echt nationen möglich
wieder ins inventar noch schnee dran
ich kenne noch oder ist das etwa kein
schnee
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft wo ihr mir
immer sachen in die kommentare spammen
könnt was ich denn in der nächsten folge
machen soll
also checks hätte dann alle diese wette
noch nicht kennen die einfach nur total
blöd sind sich meine alten videos
anzugucken nicht das ist eine serie wo
ich immer noch ein paar sachen mache sei
es im real life wo ich dann zum beispiel
mal die hände über kreuz nehmen dann
spiele oder im spiel wo das spiel auf
den kopf ist oder ich so komische shader
drin habe oder wo einfach die steuerung
verstellt ist alles ganz komisch aber
mir wurde jetzt eine coole sache wieder
in die kommentare geschrieben und zwar
ich sollte meine dicken winter an
schwimmer nehmen und mit denen dann
versuchen zu spielen ihr seht so wie bei
einer normalen hände die handschuhe sind
circa doppelt so dick dementsprechend
passt hier auch zwei mal ne wa ist die
taste rein und ich hab grad schon eine
runde probe gespielt ist es mega schwer
ich hoffe ich ziehe jetzt mal an ich
hoffe ihr vertraut mir dass ich die an
hab sonst hoffe ich mal einfach 60 jetzt
mal gerade eben an damit die italiener
ihre live dabei seid sitzt immer noch
die den anderen hier den einen habe ich
schon an hier
hallo so in zehn anderen als ich denke
man wird es dann auch an meiner
spielweise sehen dass ich dann so ein
bisschen anders spielen werde
hälfte des videos sieht damit verbracht
diese blöden handschuhe anzuziehen
früher habe ich nur eine runde
aufgenommen dann habe ich die form
spieler angezogen geht es direkt los ein
bisschen komisch also hier sind meine
handschuhe durch die damit jetzt hier
drauf sowie das mausrad zu drehen dass
allein schon mega schwer
ich glaube das wäre wieder richtig viele
runden so ich glaube meine game menü
sowie games
so da geht es rein stellen klasse wählen
nein nein nicht die ganze zeit auf nein
die ganze zeit auf kuh geht es doch gut
aussehen mehr weiß ob und nein es ist
unmöglich zu sprinten es ist unmöglich
zu sprinten
es ist nahezu unmöglich weil ich immer
auf krücken dann wahrscheinlich ein item
wegschmeißen oder und internet ag und
die maus wechsel um ein gottes willst du
schrecklich also wie hier na ja ich
hab's an
ich habe jetzt auch keine kamera frei
die ich dann auch eben für den
restlichen kann ok der staat das
wichtigste
9 drücken nein
läuft doch okay gut ich habe ein schwert
ich habe ein schwert das ist schon mal
gut
so jetzt bin ich mal im sprinten drin
das heißt wird es erstmal weg laufen und
kisten suchen und fand das kennfeld
verstehe ich kenne finde ich nicht mehr
so soll ich mal schon den ersten fight
gehe nicht die maschine den ersten fall
dass gar keiner ich kann ja in der
ersten zeit gehen so was hab ich denn
überhaupt fit bruder habe ich glaube ich
also immer noch immer noch die
handschuhe an
so hoffen wir mal hier ein händler
kisten houston als schwert so gut wie
geworden nein habe ich nicht weil ich
mir händ gehandicapt bin hier durch
tätig war ist noch viel mehr drin also
dass das habe ich gerade getestet ob das
noch diese andere andere babu kiste da
ist wo h steht darauf barricaid aktiven
alterns acht das so weil wir uns hier
sehr richtig cool hier gibt es nämlich
auch schneestürme und so was alles und
auch so wie gesagt hier barrikaden die
ich aufstellen kann die dann irgendwie
zu einer barrikade alt werden
ok cool ich weiß noch nicht was es jetzt
bringt aber es ist eine barrikade
somit kann man special move it takes
machen das brauch ich nicht aber ich
nehme auch mit da gibt es die zahl noch
höher
hier geht's nicht na gut so so sind halt
blöd ich kann diese teile dieses teil
nicht in die hand nehmen und sprinten es
auch echt komisch irgendwie war darum
geht es gar nicht
ich glaub mal her wir sind schon zwölf
leute tot ich hätte echt gedacht wir
sterben mit als erstes seltener für okay
weil und eine feder okay ich würde sagen
ein bischof dollar oder kollege wissen
auf also wie schon gesagt schreibt mir
sachen in die kommentare
ich bin einfallslos wie ein stück code
museum kloster wegen wegen gewaltsam
kite geschlossen
also leute das ist so echt das heftigste
was ich bisher bei den jacks mitgemacht
habe ich weiß das sag ich oft aber
diesmal wirklich mit solchen handschuhen
zu spielen ist echt nationen möglich
wieder ins inventar scheiße hier waren
wir noch nie dran
ich kenne noch
oder ist das etwa kein schnee keine
ahnung dass es ist jetzt so viel wasser
auf einmal ich keine ahnung was es ist
und da stellt mir mit mir keine drogen
und ich mag auch nicht mit backpulver
mohammadi mette schön was muss ich sagen
so jetzt auch einfach mal nichts sie
sonst als sonst mache ich jetzt gleich
mal hier geht es ja immer noch hören
auch menschlich gewesen hier als aber
auch nix am start
ich werde gleich sterbe ich irgendwie
war das sie also eine falle ist jetzt
aber auch nicht lang
geht es hier eventuell auch aber es
gehört dort eine nachricht bekommen
ich hab da hinten aber gerade am
horizont
da ist ein name soll ich wünsche mir
eben auch mal du bist du bist du besser
ich sag noch oder ist sein name bisschen
weiter weg auf einem chip direkt hinter
mir 'oh mein gott aber das machen wir
nochmal das war relativ kurz scheiße
weil ich gerade mainz mainz werts witzen
war gut
den kompass ist natürlich auch verwenden
können return to hat wie so was richtig
die connected to deserve please try
again later so gay manual games so jetzt
gehen wir hier ein dass natürlich das
coole an diesem server
jetzt soll der staat
werd ich akw jetzt eine zunge
rausgestreckt pausen das habe ich immer
wenn ich so komisch fokussiert bin auch
etwas so aber das war ich so blöd da auf
einmal hört auf zu springen und ich habe
auch die ganze zeit zwischen
ich merke es richtig viele leute da mir
her sind so vielleicht nicht extra wegen
mir aber einfach nur hinter mir sind wo
ich gerade schon geboxt ist es deren
erich wappis dich ist es mein erster tod
besteht denn nicht als ob der so lange
überlebt hat mit so einer verdammten
weder oder war das so hat der bischof
trainiert dann den building trennen
vielleicht muss man schwert ein schwert
ist dabei kaputt gegangen richtig nah
ist das kann doch nicht sein oder
oder muss das tue ich mich jetzt ist das
irgendwie so dass dies nicht abschalte
hä
das verstehe ich jetzt rechtlich hätte
hose ist raus dessen typ lauf forest ich
kann nicht fünf drücken weil ich hätte
dann drei dann sich auf einmal ganzen
bildschirm vor mit zahlen dabei
eigentlich glaube er hat mich nicht
gewählt
so eine scheiße drin die ich alle schon
besitze ich habe meine hand so weit von
der also meine rechte an so weit von der
keilschrift teppich seine politik ist
gerne den kampf okay
oha geld einfach bogen hat einfach ein
bogen wie soll ich da auch machen ich
habe nichts kommen dadurch was soll ich
denn da machen leute die gehen zu zweit
auf mich drauf die blöde an manchmal die
ärgern mich mama die sind böse wenn man
die ärgern mich nein nein ich glaube auf
einmal nach links an katharina geradeaus
laufen wollte kam ich nicht irgendwer
beschützen oder so von euch hier
irgendwer
ich mache auch team mit euch ja da sind
zwei andere gewesen nein die sind noch
hinter mir aber eine kiste drin
das sind zwei andere ich glaube die so
zusammen eine falle wenn ich das
hinkriege
so kommt kommt kommt oder die machen
jetzt viererteam das war heftig so ich
war einst kommen 1 1 geht noch hier noch
einmal survival games so
nein sprinten erst mal laufen lernt sei
ein ganz normaler auf immerhin 9
ich sehe schon wieder diese ganzen hält
kommentare prasseln du bist so schlecht
aber sie spulen uhr vorziehen entsteht
stellen wo ich sterbe und sehe nicht was
ich an meinen fingern halte ich verdammt
nochmal dicksten handschuhe die es gibt
auf der ganzen welt drauf nein
los gehts noch einzudrücken yourope es
leben die kiste se schon leer
ich hab keinen fall fällt mir dazu ein
ich glaube jetzt mal einfach hier noch
komplett oben mehr hoffnung ist da recht
mini-gewinn von rhein mosel sind ja auch
kisten irgendwas sprinter doch mal die
buren bock du bist du kannst dich mal so
laufen das lawa die krise zu ich bin da
das war die horror vision dass ich immer
cool drücke wenn man einmal sprinten
drin ist dann geht's an kiste
19.8 anziehen ende seine kiste sei ganz
normal laufen
so sehen wir am sprint wenn man sich
richtig krass konzentriert geht es wenn
man normal spielt geht es nicht ich habe
zwei pfeile das unglaublich so auf dem
bogen
acom liga ich krieg die krise ich hasse
es so feinarbeit zu machen
ich höre ich mein ganzer körper
kribbelig können umschlag ich hasse
feinarbeit könnt ihr dieses könnt ihr
das denn wenn es kleine sachen nicht
laufen dass sie dann einfach so macht
jetzt weil sie nicht so müsst ihr nicht
auch noch irgendwo eine kiste sein mag
es ja toll ich bin ich zu blöd fleisch
zu essen
dieser komische steuerung ihr nein sind
über diese horror momente wenn man dann
so kurzzeitig aufhört zu sprinten
ich brauche doch nur in schweden kommen
die rüstungsteile die schon besitze
eu weit herunter dass mittlerweile
bestimmt der andere typ her kennt
indymac jetzt nix herz an die kiste
schwert bitte ein schwert
da springe ich jetzt mal lieber nicht
runter kommen jetzt wir müssen wir
machen jetzt wir lassen jetzt einfach
mal die heftigsten bogen erstmals mit
chicken teriyaki alle die mir bei
instagram dot com / laser luke folgen
wissen dass dies mein lieblings sandwich
ist mein lieblingsbild willst ich komme
und gibt ihren pilz hallo kisten wollte
nicht auch halle rufen kommt rufen wir
alle web apps gibt mir eine typ
die ich hier mal runter und hier und wir
schwimmen meine rollen aber der sache
ich habe jetzt zweimal getroffen es
fängt er vielleicht so oder hat weil er
nicht fragt immer noch hier mit den hat
schon beim start meiner lieben freunde
die ich bin ich bin im arsch
und da hinten wartet auch ein tipp auf
mich team war dass der nächste nicht der
scheiße ich drehe mich extra um darum
der piste doch nur darauf dass ich komme
in seinem haus rein
so und jetzt laufe ich und wenn da kommt
dann laufen wir sind jetzt bei hinter
mir ich will gar keinen gerade hab noch
einen dicken bauch gesehen
jetzt muss ich ihnen einen tollen
manövern abhängen
also eher blöd hält drop incoming 88
erinnern die koordinaten an wo die kiste
ihn kommen bei der bahn
doch da unten der minister der sieben
ich liebe ihn nicht nur als gewichtig in
arth gefegt es ist hinten
ach das ist die zeit die so schnell
vorbeigeht das ist krass das cool der
spiele selten survival games ich merkte
dass nicht mehr so die ganzen neuen ich
bin halt so dann suchen wir uns jetzt
mal ein paar kisten
es ist keiner mehr hinter provision
inventar oder altem wegschmeißen
wenn ich die sachen einfach abbauen
könnten nicht so viel eisen gold pig
mich jeder bessere sachen als ich und
ich hab an schuh an der nase drauf
einmal wir ja gut freuen ich habe drei
runden gespielt mit diesen handschuhen
ich war nie ich glaube ich war immer in
der überlebenden hälfte die besser waren
alle schreibt freuen ich hoffe euch hat
trotzdem bisschen gefallen dass ich mit
dieser hand schon mal gespielt habe bin
ich habe es war auf jeden fall kacke ich
konnte nichts reißen sonst hätte ich
eventuell besser weglaufen können hätten
kästen auch am anfang ich dann mal ein
paar sachen herausnehmen können aber
sonst freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
lasten daumen nach oben auf jeden fall
wenn ihr mehr von challenge accepted
haben wollte es leben nur noch neun
leute naja gut und schreiben auf jeden
fall ganz genau was ich machen soll das
kann auch so etwas sein wie
beispielsweise das spiel zum beispiel
games und nimmt keine waffen oder sowas
kann es auch sein oder spielweise games
und immer wenn
jemand stiert musst du dir irgendwo an
einem gesicht eine wäscheklammer
befestigen keine ahnung dass dir da
haben wollt ja auch noch alles voll
geschwitzt